[Music]
are you ready for the uk
transition number four resources
and support
hello my name is jane rose and i'm head
of international trade at the essex
chambers of commerce
this is the last of four bite-sized
videos about the uk transition
which have been commissioned by rochford
district council to help businesses
prepare
for the changes to trading with the eu
in this final video
i want to look at what resources are out
there and where you can find information
and training to help you prepare for the
uk transition
contact and website details are listed
in the video description
a good place to start is our essex
chambers uk transition website page
we've selected core information to help
you find what you need
quickly and we're updating the site all
of the time
we're running lots of online training
courses that can help you with all
aspects of importing and exporting
but i can't stress enough that you need
to learn about customers processes
especially if you've never traded
outside of the eu
but there is government funding
available for training staff
and it software if you're thinking of
making your own customs declarations
it might be useful to connect to the
government agencies that provide
guidance for specific sectors like food
and drink for example
and you should find out what
certificates licenses or other
arrangements might be needed
you should also look at packaging and
labeling requirements for your products
are there changes how will you label
your products and what type of pallets
can be used
you should also review any contracts you
have in place
if you use inco terms which set out the
responsibility between the buyer and the
seller
you'll need to check how the transition
affects those responsibilities
find out if you're going to need to
produce export documentation
like certificates of origin or customs
documents
essex chambers can help you with this
you'll also need to make sure that you
know the origin of your goods
where they originate from not just where
they're imported from
and you'll need proof of origin you'll
need to refer to the uk global tariff
and the exporters trade tool to see what
commodity codes and duties will be for
your products
and you should be aware of changes that
will impact the transportation of your
goods speak with your transport and
logistics providers
if you're importing and exporting to
northern ireland you need to sign up to
the traders
support service this will guide you
through any changes due to the
implementation of the northern ireland
protocol
is not just physical goods that are
affected if you're providing services in
the eu
you need to check the national
regulations on the government selling
services guide
i would advise looking at the border
operating model it is a huge document
and it won't all apply to you but
everything you need to know
is in there finally sign up for the
government updates and alerts
and stay informed there's a lot to think
about and not a lot of time to prepare
if you haven't already
on behalf of essex chambers and rochford
district council
we hope the videos have been of help to
you and please do contact us if you need
help
my final advice would be to find out
where the responsibilities lie for you
as a business all of the links to the
topics i've spoken about
and the government guidance can be found
in the video descriptions together with
contact details
thank you so much for listening
[Music]
you